hello and welcome to this special
edition of spectator tv i'm your host
today cindy yoo i'm the broadcast editor
and i'm joined by james forsythe our
political editor and frozen nelson the
spectators editor
now we were expecting the wakefield and
tibetan and 1010 by-elections to be lost
by the conservatives but i think nobody
quite expected by how much
james what we saw was a collapse of the
lib down vote in one constituency in
support of labour and the reverse in
another one so are we seeing a return of
tactical voting i think the big worry
for the tories looking at last night's
results is that we appear to be heading
back to a kind of 1997 style situation
where politics is divided into tories
and anti-tories and the anti-tories are
prepared to vote tactically to unseat
the tory uh look at tivoton in 2017 and
2019 labour came second in that seat
last night they lost their deposit now
that's not because people in that part
of devon are particularly unpersuaded by
kierstarma it is because voters and
tiverson looked at it and thought right
well the lib dems could beat the tories
here even though they were fired last
time labour can't and so they moved all
mass to the liberal democrats and the
worry for the tories is and in wakefield
you saw tactically a smaller version of
this but the lib dem vote from an albeit
from a small base halved they lost their
deposit and labour won
and i think the worry for the tories is
that if you look at the polls and you
add together label in the dems and the
green in crude terms that anti-tory
block is about 60
if they start voting tactically and
and in the vast majority of seats it is
obvious who you should vote to try and
unseat the tory then that could be
absolutely devastating for the tory
party and one of the biggest questions
for them going forward now is how do you
defang tactical voting well fraser is it
all about boris johnson is that what is
fanging this uh this collaboration going
on if he left would this tactical voting
continue
i'm afraid i think it would i mean yes
boris johnson is his negative is now
quite strong if you look at on the
spectator data hub we're tracking his
unbobularity and it's now pretty much
down there with tony blair just nadir
even theresa may and but if you take
away boris johnson are people going to
be enthralled with the conservative
party right now i'm not sure that they
will they're going to think of a party
that promised to manifest a pledge not
to cut tanks it's not not to increase
taxes but that's exactly what they've
done a party that's brought a runaway
inflation and and
combined with the strike chaos you get a
general sense of tory chaos not boris
johnson chaos but tory chaos now this is
why boris johnson is still in place
nobody doubts that he has become a
lightning conductor right now and as
james says that's why you see an
auditory vote because if you're curious
armor you'd be absolutely distraught
you've got four percent of the vote into
written i mean that is not a great
endorsement way nor lower than labour
normally gets but is tactical voting
but when you look at the people most
likely to succeed boris johnson you
still don't have a very attractive list
you right now you've got jeremy hunt
still easily the favorite to succeed now
how many people think that jeremy hunt
is the answer to the problems right now
but after joining me hunt you've got tom
tugan hats penny mordant liz truss when
the conservatives start to think about
those four they think can we be sure
they'd be so much better than boris
johnson to be worth the drama of
deposing a sitting prime minister so
until there is a clear alternative
you're going to end up in this limbo but
i don't think we're looking at a limbo
where the tories tread water they seem
to be going down quite a lot and with
various sort of panicked policies there
i mean in james's and james today writes
about this how they're planning to um
make it easier to outlaw airbnbs in
certain parts of england you know
businesses are the tories used to be all
against these kind of policies now
they're panicked they're flailing and
it's very hard to say what the
conservatives stand for so i think yes
boris johnson's a problem but a lack of
any idea of what the conservatives stand
for that's not the problem james for one
person for whom boris johnson is a
problem is oliver dowden the party
chairman or former party chairman i
should say because he resigned you know
as soon as these results came out tell
us about this intriguing resignation
letter that he wrote so oliver down is
the party chairman in a party law this
year he used to work for david cameron
uh he's prepared you know
umpteen tory leaders for prime
minister's questions
and in 2019 he was one of three people
along with robert jenner and received
right saying you know look the tory
party is in a hole and the only person
who can get out of that hole is boris
johnson and that was seen by many people
as a sign that you know people should
put their doubts aside for the good of
the tory party the only person who could
get them out of a brexit hole they dug
themselves into was boris johnson so
turn to him and take the risk
and i think what's striking about this
letter is uh he says someone must take
responsibility uh it can um a bit can't
we business as usual now the
responsibility line is interesting
because when you lose a buyer action in
one of the safest story seats in the
country on an almost 30 swing you can't
say that that is about the micro details
of a campaign if you put the leaflets
out in a different order that would have
made the difference so that begs the
question of why he is taking
responsibility when it's clearly not a
kind of tactical campaigning issue
and then i thought what was very
interesting was his last line is i will
as always remain loyal to a conservative
party and this is so striking because
there is no line in there saying that he
remains loyal to boris johnson that he
continues to support boris johnson as
leader but he will support
boris johnson's leader from the back
benches and what i think oliver darwin
is saying in a kind of coded way
is he now thinks that he's launched the
conservative party and his policies of
boris johnson's leadership are in
conflict and so he has resigned because
fraser you know for all of the policy
issues the macro issues that you're
mentioning in the course of living
crisis inflation
you know all of these things you're
you're right to say that these are
things that people are unhappy about but
fundamentally it's also about boris
jones and prosperity it's about
partygate the way he handled it you know
this weird time story about potentially
giving his wife carrie a job in
government all these ideas that combine
to make it seem as if the government
doesn't play by the same rules under
boris johnson presumably to all
employees feel the same way and want to
you know have someone new even if the
choices are not amazing yes of course
this um really annoys tory mps but also
by the time the next general election
comes i suspect partygate will not be
that big a factor the biggest factor
where people's salaries will be going
down in real terms by 5 or 10
and they'll be asking does the does this
government have any plans to get us out
of this mess i think that will quickly
become the bigger and far more
substantial issue and if the government
has no plans other than trying to ape
labor policies then why not and go with
with kyo starmer i was talking to a
senior conservative this morning and is
saying that right now
the blair government was actually more
reliable in many ways better than this
conservative government at least it was
predictable this tory government is not
predictable whereas you know you're
seeing the windfall taxes that they used
to be against there's talk of stealing
the tariffs being slapped down as well
next week and another panicked response
so when you see a tory party which is
weak and panicked this is the opposite
of the tory party which might be
penalized for having a strong agenda
people might disagree with this looks
like a party that's falling apart
so i do think these problems are going
to get worse
um and this is why i think how no matter
how bad things look with the
conservatives i think they can get
significantly worse because i can easily
foresee boris johnson being replaced by
a new leader he's got even less of a
clue
himself
um james on the spectator's data hub we
have a poll tracker which shows that
there's a seven percentage lead for
labour at the moment should we be
expecting a
bigger lead essentially at this point in
time yeah i think what is quite clear
from these results
is that labour's result in wakefield was
good but not spectacular and
i think when you combine the two results
and the polls there's more of an
anti-tory vote out there than there is a
pro-labor or pro-stamina vote i still
think that the most likely result of the
next election is an anti-tory majority
in the next parliament
and i think but i think in some ways you
know
stoma
storm is
storm is still you know in that
situation solomon kirsan would still end
up as prime minister now he would not
you know and so we we should keep in
perspective how it is now i think it is
quite clear
that uh things that would not improve
the tory party's mood would be if
kirsten ended up being pushed out and
there was a labour leadership election i
was talking to one tory minister
yesterday
who said to me that he'd heard a rumor
that the durham police decision was
coming tomorrow
and he looked kind of panicked about it
not not kind of gleefully rubbing his
hands oh they will have to have a
leadership contest it's like oh crikey
we could not have to face lisa nandy and
that would be more difficult for us uh
you know and i think that i think that
the problem is but what the on the labor
side the alternatives to kirsten these
and anthony we're streeting are seen as
being more electrically appealing than
he is i think the problem on the tory
side for boris johnson is this is
he is still the biggest figure in
british politics he still dominates
but the problem at the moment is his
dominance is now harming him um i was
very struck talking to one cabinet
minister who is loyal to him
uh
he said to me after a a by-election
visit that that what worried him
and this is someone who's been
knowledgeable johnson for for a very
long time
uh
is
that
boris johnson at the moment is
motivating the anti-tory vote more than
the tory vote and so the these people
are kind of you know want to get up in
the morning and go and give him a kick
while as the tory vote doesn't
necessarily want to come out and and
support him and i think i mean that is
difficult and then i think to fraser's
point i think one of the things that is
causing tory warriors governments are
generally unpopular in midterm and it is
true that this government is not
spectacularly unpopular for a midterm
government but often when governments
are unpopular in midterm they're on
problem in time because they are because
they are doing something tough but
necessary so the coalition went for a
period of unpopularity because it it
tried to restrain public spending and
their people didn't like that now
tory mps kind of understood why they
were unpopular at the moment tory mps
know that they're unpopular but they
don't understand the kind of
what what they are getting out of the
unpopularity if you see what i mean you
know they're not getting a kind of
smaller state out of being unpopular
they're not taking
the toughest of decisions and so i think
that this unpopularity
irritates them for that reason they
can't they can't see the point of it
absolutely and frasier just finally
let's talk about the tory party what are
you hearing how are people feeling about
this in particular as boris johnson is a
way out of the country and will be over
the more than a week well the main
discussion is when to make a second
attempt at trying to depose him and
there is a consensus amongst the rebels
i think they're quite right in this and
realizing they cannot afford to botch it
a second time they can as james was
saying in a cover story a couple of
weeks ago change the rules to get to
have another go technically we've not
allowed to for another year but they can
change the rules and do that but if they
were to do that and fail then it would
be graham brady who has to resign the
chair of 1922 committee as opposed to
boris johnson so they would have to be a
hundred percent sure but they would have
numbers to get rid of boris and there
would have to be a far clearer idea
about what should follow right now is
just a bit of a mush they know they
didn't like the situation a but they
can't really agree in what situation b
should be so they need to start
discussing not necessarily who's going
to be the next leader but what sort of
policies do they want do they want to um
should they be going to the left or to
the right should they be trying to copy
labor policies and deal labor that way
or trying to make a better case for
conservative questions
i mean in a way boris johnson's actually
a distraction from the far more
important question if how would you do
it differently if there is no real
consensus in that question but they're
stuck
to remain in this kind of purgatory one
of the very interesting points james
makes in his analysis this morning is
that the what james calls the coalition
of left you know labor lib dems the snp
are run about 60 percent of the votes
right now so sure you say the labor is
only seven points ahead but it doesn't
look like very much but when you look at
these parties aligned together because
what we've seen in this by-election is
this is now effectively what the tories
are up against it's not labor it is
whatever mandatory forces there are and
in which case if the coalition never
left is it sixty percent inventories um
are far less than that then there is a
problem and i think for when it comes to
the next election that is perhaps now
the graph to watch
and the problem is the conservative
party they know and somebody needs to
find an answer to this but they're not
sure who and we've got even less idea
what that answer should be
well james and fraser thank you very
much and you can be sure that spectator
tv and the spectator will be here when
we try to find the answer to that
question thanks for watching
you